si va ai miei amici sono stupidi che il
tuo cugino preferito saverio e thomas
che la tua amica del cuore il mio cugino
preferito saverio la mia amica del cuore
sei tutta la massa
ciao e benvenuto il nuovo video oggi
risponderò a delle domande domande che
ho chiesto su instagram e alle quale
risponderò proprio oggi a queste domande
che aste su instagram dire iniziare a
rispondere alle domande quelle di
instagram numero e l'indirizzo di
gianmarco allora gianmarco vive il suo
numero e ottenuto subito è
tu illustrato ancora insieme
no noi quando ci vediamo facciamo le
vacanze insieme ci siamo di bacetti e
dell'amicizia quale è stata la tua
esperienza al liceo consigli perché
frequenta l'ultimo anno fanno finire
prima possibile hai mai avuto animali
domestici oltre ad enrico sì ho un altro
cane che si chiama murdoch
le tartarughe prospero e non era la
vostra esp e con la massima crisi e
bluetooth
però non aveva come l'altra volta in età
precoce
perché invece browser diciamo che
l'animale domestico più importante
dovuto per tanto tempo e proprio aricò
dove preso qualcosa che si attacca al
vetro mentre tagli la barba su amazon
che mette il link qua sotto enrico sa di
essere stato adottato si la sentenza che
fosse una battuta poi ti abbiamo fatto
vedere i documenti
suo padre era un messicano sono ormai
era una foca che il rapporto ai quei
tuoi fratelli giudicando poi i rapporti
che vedo in giro è tipo idilliaco
evidentemente siamo quattro fratelli
molto molto molto molto molto legati là
fuori c'è gente che si accoltella alle
spalle che per 10 euro si ammazzerebbe
questa è una cosa che non ci appartiene
e sicuramente è stato diciamo una delle
eredità della famiglia da parte di mia
mamma e mio nonno ma non è sempre stato
così quando eravamo più piccoli
specialmente dio e
alcuni andavano molto in contrasto e ci
ammazzavamo di botte e gli insulti poi
quando cresci diciamo che ai due opzioni
o continui a fare il bambino trasmetti
scopri che in realtà dietro a tutta
quella rabbia c'è un grande affetto
esiste qualcosa che non mangi da quanto
seguì drag race stagione preferita dalla
preferita la seconda anni stagione
preferita la sesta gara preferita la
vincitrice bianca del rio ad una
cattiveria specialmente quando e comica
perché preferisce il bene perché più
succoso che ne pensi della bigotta gene
e con cui volo apostrofato ariana grande
che ha fatto scusa
fabio volo da della [ __ ] dariana
grande perché insulto video è tutto un
riferimento sessuale non è possibile se
le gare come cantante si metta a quattro
zampe vestire la [ __ ] e muovere il
culo dicendo
l'ho visto mi piace lo voglio cielo lo
prendo la canzone non l'ho sentita
severamente dice queste cose ma canzone
abbastanza forte ma deve esser sincero
io lo trovo forte anche negli uomini
cioè non sto facendo un discorso per cui
una donna non può cantare un testo
eccessivamente sessuale invece un uomo
può dire ossei bella vieni al candy shop
ti faccio leccare il lollipop no va bene
un po danno fastidio
entrambe le cose aide rimpianti un sacco
tornassi indietro ci sono un po di cose
che farei diversamente fare delle scelte
di studio diverse farei delle scelte
lavorative diverse e sicuramente
sentimentali diverse però se non avessi
fatto delle scelte sbagliate e molto
probabilmente non avere questo tipo di
consapevolezza
hai mai subito discriminazioni per il
tuo orientamento se sì come ha risposto
si ci vorrei rimanere un male forse
anche perché ero il primo a provare una
forma di omofobia nei miei confronti ho
una forma di senso di colpa
per esempio c'è stato un ragazzo mi ha
fatto no no no i [ __ ] cioè devono stare
lontani da meno st allontani da me no no
che poi appena viene fatto guarda
tranquillo cioè io soffro cio mamma e
perciò sono i ragazzi belli è rimasto si
destinazione da sogno tokyo o quelle
robe tipo l'isola di pasqua la polinesia
francese
questi posti meravigliosi lontani dal
mondo che vedrai una volta nella tua
vita se da culo viaggio più bello che
hai fatto perché sicuramente è stato
completino express e le filippine perché
ho vissuto le filippine come nessun
turista arriverà mai messo insieme ad
alice che è stata una compagna di
viaggio meravigliosa ed ero in un posto
stupendo crudele e spietato ma allo
stesso tempo stupendo vaia mai a
curiosare sui profili dei tuoi follower
sì mi capita una cosa che più mi piace
che secondo me non avete idea delle
persone che che stalker o che comunque
controllo questa cosa non dovrei dirlo
mi vergogno luigi conosceva e seguiva
willwoosh prima di conoscere guglielmo
grazie a dio la ne sto sudando per
prendere l'a21 sopra ti supplico
sticazzi ragazzi sto per mettere un
ventilatore sentire tenuto
di sottofondo vi supplico ti sei mai
innamorato di una donna assolutamente sì
mi sono infatuata di tre ragazze diciamo
medie liceo e università
non ho mai fatto nulla per il semplice
fatto che essendo consapevole della mia
preferenza non avrei voluto prendere in
giro
qualcuna o farne parte del tempo ciao
buche genere di libri leggere letto i
grandi classici della letteratura leggi
spesso di rado allora io leggo tanto la
cosa che io preferisco e mettermi al
buio a letto con il kindle
personalmente preferisco tutto quello
che rientra nel fantasy thriller
fantascienza gli piacciono molto le
storie che non sono bene tra virgolette
e che mi permettono un pochino di uscire
dalla quotidianità dalla routine di
alimentare l'immaginazione di classici
nolletti russi inglesi anche italiani
alcuni li ho amati alcuni le odiati e
basta ciao come siete sempre così
affiatati in famiglia o vi scannate pure
vuoi in famiglia nostra non ci si scanna
tutti contro tutti
però ogni tanto si attivano delle delle
coppie quest'estate vogliamo ricordare
il litigio fra ieri quella vigna io
stavo sotto la doccia a un certo punto
ho sentito urla disumane
sono uscito c'era del fango per terra e
si stavano picchiando e poi però ho
anche sentito quando ricevono facciamo
pace e io ero lì dietro e loro si
abbracciavano ridicoli e patetici
quanto pensi sia difficile oggi fare
qualcosa di innovativo originale nel
mondo del tubo difficilissimo ma ancora
più difficile secondo me fare un
qualcosa che rappresenti molto chi sei
oggi si vedono un sacco di persone che
seguono trend è un sacco di persone che
impostano contenuti tanto per farlo io
trovo che sia veramente difficile
riuscire magari ogni settimana a tirar
fuori qualcosa che ti rappresenti che
sia in qualche modo innovativo nuovo
originale come scoprire se un ragazzo
etero sia gay
pregadio com'è lavorare con i propri
parenti lavorare in famiglia può essere
molto divertente come nel caso nostro o
molto molto terribile come nel caso di
altre persone che si
cannes ne succedono non faccio nomi ho
visto delle cose folli piatto preferito
in assoluto è piatto odiato in assoluto
mi verrebbe da dire una buona buona
buona buona carbonara qual è il piatto
preferito
quando manchi magica vergona ecco perché
ingrassa ho visto mangia molto più sushi
che calcolava sicuramente di sushi il
piatto che mangio di più è il sushi
se non ci ha fatto di più non è il
preferito è lo so i crudi di pesce bio
commenti ok il mio piatto più odiato
quelle cose tipo la trippa minestrone
dammi le verdure non darmi st bagnarola
roba lì cioè che oscena quale
sceglieresti tra lo scrivere come
shakespeare e dipingere come botticelli
shakespeare aveva delle belle trame non
mi piace come scrive totti l'ho detto
notti cellino
non è il mio ma mai detto scrivere come
kafka e dipingere come caravaggio
preferirei scrivere come shakespeare se
questa è la domanda che devo dipingere
io se invidioso il fatto che cracco
abbia scelto camilla e non te per il
nuovo programma di cucina sono invidioso
del camilla abbia scelto gracco invece
che mi ha posto il programma di prestiti
biscotti preferite i tuoi occhi pan di
stelle le gocciole extra dark i cookies
i ringo ayoreo quanto vuoi bene enrico
molto poco ci parli dello spettacolo per
all aids è uno spettacolo che sarà a
milano vi lascio il link qua sotto di
base quello che facciamo è informazione
riguardo la che vuole di s secondo me
vale la pena prendere un biglietto per
fare una cosa buona
nei confronti degli altri e anche nei
confronti di se stessi il fatto che
abbia iniziato a vedere video porno gay
fa di me un omosessuale non per forza
anche un curioso se è attratto da quello
che vede c'è una forma di attrazione per
che sembri triste forse perché lo sono
la tua definizione di arte se esiste la
possibilità di dire qualcosa senza
doverlo spiegare dire qualcosa in
maniera non convenzionale come fai ad
avere sempre il sorriso stampato in
faccia attingo c'è ed è felice se cambia
ed è triste
ciao come è nata la tua passione per il
web un abbraccio forte volevo fare cose
ma il mondo che aveva attorno mi
permetteva di farle il web invece si è
così mi sono rimboccato le maniche ho
iniziato a applicarmi sul web abbastanza
chiaro non pensi di fare un lavoro
troppo precario si sa mai pensato di
andare via dall'italia questo è il mio
sogno
ci penso ancora mi piacerebbe vivere a
londra mi piacerebbe vivere a new york
odio fare il turista mi piace vivere i
posti quindi l'idea di lavorare in uno
di questi mi farebbe impazzire in italia
è una storia lunga magari la spiegherò
più avanti very good
un pizza come ha vissuto il tuo
daltonismo quando era adolescente allora
la cosa divertente che non mi sono reso
conto subito cioè ero piccolino e
devono essere mi diceva ma perché ho
fatto il tronco dell'albero rossomanno è
marrone ma perché hai fatto la pelle
della principessa grigia e non rosa
marrone e rosso blu e viola con fondo
grigio chiaro e rosa con fondo un
determinato tipo di arancione e di verde
e da lì matite giotto con sopra scritto
il colore hai qualche tatuaggio se sì
quali e dove e cosa significano per te
no non ho tatuaggi non riesco a
decidermi su quale sia il mio colore
preferito immaginati mettermi addosso
un'immagine una scritta un simbolo e
rimarrà lì per tutta la vita però mi
piacciono molto sugli altri così
tantissimo qual è il libro che rileggere
sti senza stancarti ma in qualsiasi cosa
scritta jonathan stroud che sia
bartimeus rudenko pazzesco oppure se
volete la risposta più [ __ ] lettera a
mio padre di kakà il tuo segno zodiacale
ascendente sagittario ascendente leone
hai mai pensato di scrivere un altro
romanzo rullo di tamburi lo sto
scrivendo da un po di tempo ma c'è
ancora un sacco di lavoro da fare e
quindi magari vi parlerò più avanti
quando sarà un pochino più concreto ci
fai un albero genealogico della famiglia
come fate essere tutti i cugini
salvatore e anna hanno dato la vita a
maria rita fiera e silvana mia mamma
margherita ha dato la vita a la v e
pierre fra zia fiera ha dato la vita
giulia gianni bea e bruce a silvana ha
dato la vita guga già ed è ed è così che
ti spiego come ci ritroviamo s10 cugini
e unico di chi eni poter dare il pilot
guglielmo aspetta un bambino di claire
persone nessuno di noi ha fatto figli
niente ci sono impegnati arti puzzano i
piedi certamente oggi particolarmente
cosa ne pensi del plastic free che ci
può impegnare quanto vuoi ma se non
parte dalle grandi aziende e dai
supermercati sarà molto difficile e
sposarlo guglielmo non è guglielmo senza
una distrazione fisso una fissa è vero
questo son capelli bianchi quelli che
vedo
qual è il tuo sogno nel cassetto cosa
avresti realizzare in un futuro non
troppo lontano scrive non storia
bellissima è in cantiere continuo a
ripeterlo devo solamente di farlo fuori
che progetti hai per il futuro
continuare a respirare e queste sono le
domande alle quali sono riuscito a
rispondere fino adesso se ne avete altre
lasciatemi le qua sotto
io vi ringrazio per aver seguito questo
video come sempre l'invito a mettermi un
bel pollice in su per iscrivervi al
canale attivare la campanella delle
notifiche ma soprattutto esserci
domenica prossima alle 12 per un nuovo
video sul canale ciao